si uno continuará con las maniobras
militares alrededor de la isla de taiwán
en represalia por la reciente visita de
la congresista nancy pelosi la agencia
de noticias oficial xinhua había dicho
la semana pasada que durarían cuatro
días y que terminarían el domingo pero
ayer ni beijing y taipei confirmaron
formalmente su final sobre las nuevas
maniobras se sabe poco ha dicho el
ejército popular de liberación que serán
ejercicios de asalto y anti submarinos
pero no se sabe aún cuándo ni dónde se
celebrarán china de hecho ya ha
levantado la alerta en las seis zonas
agarraron alrededor de la isla donde
había prohibido el tráfico aéreo y
taiwán ha dicho hoy que sus vuelos han
empezado a recobrar la normalidad
después de la cascada de cancelaciones y
cambios de rumbo
taiwán por su parte ha anunciado y sus
propias maniobras serán el martes y el
jueves son ejercicios con fuego real y
que ensayan ensayarán un escenario de
invasión china sigue por lo tanto el
fragor en la isla y ya advirtió china
ayer que se reservaba el derecho de s
ejerciendo maniobras militares de forma
rutinaria en lo que se entendió como un
aviso a la presidenta sainz wen para que
cese con las acciones que pekín entiende
como hostiles